- It's funny that you say
it like the School Days
like Mal is either like 10 or two.
- That's, yeah.
- I was definitely one of
those people who put it at 10.
- I know you did it you piece of shit
'cause I knew exactly what my-
- What is going on here?
- School Day sucks.
(upbeat music)
Welcome to Trash Taste episode three.
I'm your host Connor CDawg
and we have the Anime man as always.
- That's me.
- And the Anime Zone.
- Man you went straight
in there, didn't you?
(laughing lightly)
- I had to. I had to
- You're like no bullshit.
Okay, let's just get this done guys.
- That was like no like prefix whatsoever.
It's like, this is Trash
Taste episode three,
I'm your host, all right.
- What else? I mean,
that's how you start it.
Then we get into the topic.
- Yeah, but you got have like,
we need to come up with some kind of like,
you know like, how Good
Mythical Morning does it?
- Yeah.
- Like the let's talk about that,
like we gotta have something like that.
- I was going to,
but you interrupted me
with the you know...
- What? I didn't interrupt
you with anything.
(laughing loudly)
- I was gonna say your
names then the topic
is gonna be smooth as fuck.
- There was no prefix
to interrupt.
- Professional.
- No, no, exactly right?
- Wow, wow, okay, ruining my turn to host.
- Okay well then go for it.
- All right go.
- This is my time to shine.
(laughing loudly)
- [Anime Zone] Go for it.
- What I would like to discuss
today with you gentlemen
is your anime origin story, if you will.
How did you get into anime?
And how you discovered
that you were gonna go
down this rapid hole of never coming back.
- This beautiful medium
that's we all love and...
- And hate
(laughing softly ).
At the same time.
- Yeah.
- Who'd like to go first.
- I mean, do you wanna go first Joey?
Because I feel like you
have the most unique-
- Yeah.
- Most likely.
- I feel you're putting the
pressure on me, all right.
- Probably have all that, right?
- Yeah, okay, having a follow up his story
is gonna be fun, but-
(laughing loudly)
- I mean it's not that exciting.
- Whatever.
- I mean, yeah,
I guess like mine is unique
in the sense that like,
would you say I'm the only
anituber that has like
grown up with anime?
And when I say growing up
I mean like from age
of conceptual thought.
(laughing softly)
- You know.
- Age of conceptual thought.
- I think just being raised in a household
to the Japanese parent,
probably has an immediately
different attitude towards anime
than one that we would
experience in Western.
- Right, because like you know,
when most people say like
"Oh I grew up with anime,
anime was my childhood."
Like you know that usually
start age 12 maybe 10.
- I mean the real question is,
did you know what anime was growing up?
- I mean, that's all I ever knew.
- Yeah exactly.
- Okay, so when you were
growing up in your head,
even at like age five or six,
there was a clear distinction between like
"Pokemon" and like I don't know
like Cartoon Network shows.
- Yeah like Batman.
- That there was a difference.
- Or "Ed, Edd and Eddy
or something like that."
- But you knew that they
wanted them as Japanese?
- Yeah, yeah because unlike
a lot of kids in Australia
and like probably around my age group.
I grew up watching "Pokemon"
and like "Dragon Ball" in Japanese.
- I have thought "Pokemon"
was an American cartoon...
- [Joey] A lot of people did.
- And my mind was blown
at like age 10 when I
heard the Japanese version
Because it's on YouTube clips, right?
And then you're like, oh
wait, this is the original?
- Yeah.
- How?
- Because to me "Pokemon"
when I was growing up,
just seemed like this very weird genre.
Like I couldn't put my finger on it.
- Yeah.
- But I felt it was a genre,
like it was "Pokemon",
"Digimon", "Cardcaptor Sakura",
which was "Cardcaptors"
in the UK and America.
- Was it actually?
- Yeah, yeah it was called Cardcaptors.
- Sakura, that's too Asian
sound get rid of that.
(laughing softly)
- And it wasn't even Sakura, it's Sakura.
- Sakura.
(laughing loudly)
- And the other girl was like,
they changed her name to Madison, I think.
I can't remember what
her original name was
but this is back in the
age of four kids dubbing.
I don't think it was a given even for kids
that dubbed "Cardcaptor Sakura."
But it was in the day that's
localization was a thing.
We were eating jelly donuts.
(laughing loudly)
- Except only Garry.
- I couldn't believe
that at the first time.
'Cause you know like, being, as you said
like growing up in an Asian
household, Japanese household.
Onigiri was just like the
most like normal concept
I've ever seen.
- Yeah, that's like
your bread.
- Yeah,
(laughing softly)
exactly, right?
It's like you know-
- What did you do to my boy?
- I know it's like, yeah,
as you said, it's like bread,
it's like watching an American cartoon
like "Dexter's Laboratory."
- Yeah.
- And like a scene of them
making toasts, for example.
(laughing softly)
And it gets over dubbed into Japanese
like you know I'm making a rice bowl.
(laughing loudly)
a flat rice ball.
- I think it's just 'cause at that time,
I remember a lot of my friends
just didn't really know the
concept of just eating rice.
If you weren't Asian you're like,
"why would you eat rice with every meal?"
That doesn't make sense.
(laughing softly)
Right, right?
- I guess so.
- Yeah, I think I can remember
what my family thinking rice was
exotic isn't that-
- [Joey] Really?
- Well I mean it was something you had
with foreign foods.
- Oh, I get.
- So, you just don't really eat rice-
- But like that's on the
contrary though, right?
Like do you eat bread with everything?
Because at least in Japan,
the concept of eating bread
with everything is like, why?
- I feel like at least in British culture
you could put bread with anything,
like you get away with it.
- Well that's true.
I guess like the food culture
of that country revolves around-
- Anyway, we're getting off topic.
(laughing softly)
We're like the food culture.
- Yeah, but so like basically,
I grew up watching "Pokemon"
and like, what else can
I remember watching?
I guess like before that
though, before "Pokemon"
or anything like that,
or you know,
before I started watching
"One Piece" or "Dragon ball"
or like all the Shaun and jump stuff,
Japanese kids grew up with this like
very certain array of kids anime,
which is just absolutely
not known overseas at all.
- Like "Doraemon."
- "Doraemon" is probably
the most well-known.
But like you don't like see
an anetuber like reviewing "Doraemon."
- Episode 5,000 review
"Doraemon" let's go.
- Right, or like you know,
like one series that I grew up watching
like alongside "Doraemon" ,
was this show called "Sazae-san."
- Which is like the longest
running Japanese anime-
- Longest running anime ever.
- Yeah, and nobody outside
of Japan has heard of it.
I didn't know about it until you...
I was having a conversation with you.
- I mean just to put it in perspective,
my mum grew up watching that show.
(laughing softly)
And I grew up watching that show.
So, it's been going on since the 60s
and I think this is like
5,000 episodes or something?
- It's ridiculous,
it's absurd.
- It's still going,
till this day.
- Yeah, I know.
- Like I don't know how,
I don't know because
like it's really weird
because the concept of that show is like,
it's just revolving around
this family living in Japan.
And it's just like the most like
normal slice of life
show that I've ever seen.
But I also think to myself like,
how can you come up with like
40 years worth of topics?
And not be like maybe
we did cover this topic
like 25 years ago,
in one of those episodes.
- There must be episodes that overlap.
Like I feel you can't
make that many episodes
and not overlap.
- No, no.
- I mean they probably
could overlap but no one's
gonna be bothered to like
watching and cross referencing.
- No one's re-watching that show, right?
It's one of those things,
if it's on TV you watch it, right?
- Yeah.
It's like, oh oh, they covered
this topic in episode 1,743.
- There's you know, there's
one super fan in Japan,
that's just seen every episode.
- Of course yeah.
- And just knows everything
about every episode.
- That seems to be "Sazae-san?"
- "Sazae-san."
- And "Doraemon" seem to
be the one thing where
if you ask anyone in
Japan, do you watch anime?
They'll be like, oh yeah,
"Doraemon" and just-
- Yeah, I grew up with
"Doraemon" and "Sazae-san."
- And then I'm like, I
mean the other anime.
- Right, right, because-
- Like anime, anime.
There's a distinction.
- There's no boobs in that, what the fuck
(laughing softly).
- I don't wanna imagine
Doraemon with boobs.
(laughing loudly)
- Oh my God.
- No God.
- That exists somewhere on the internet.
- Please don't.
- But watching "Doraemon"
and like "Sazae-san"
and I could list off a number of shows
but no one would probably know.
But like there's just like
a certain number of shows
that I think like it's
just become tradition now,
no matter what generation
or like if you're born
and raised in the city
or you know, the middle of nowhere.
Every kid grows up watching these
like really specific set of shows.
And that's just like normal to them.
That's like watching you know "Peppa Pig."
- [Both] Yeah.
- It's just like
you don't even think about
like, oh yes it's a cartoon.
It's just something on the TV.
- It's a show.
- And then, yeah, I guess like
the concept of anime, anime,
didn't hit me until maybe like,
at least when I started
watching "One piece"
and "Dragon Ball."
And probably around the
like "Pokemon" time.
So I reckon when I was
like five or six years old.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- So when you started
realizing what anime is
and probably getting into it.
That's when probably we started to
watch our first animated,
which was "Pokemon."
- Right, right, right.
But like in my head I'm like,
yeah, "Pokemon" is an anime
and like "Samurai Jack" is a cartoon.
Because at that time around
five or six years old
that's when I started like
watching Cartoon Network.
And I'd like to think
that we grew up in like the
golden age of cartoon network.
- I mean...
- I'd say so.
- We had "Samurai Jack."
- Yeah yeah.
- We had "Samurai Jack," "Dexter's Lab,"
"Cow and Chicken," "Ed, Edd n Eddy,"
so many amazing shows.
And to me it's like, okay
things on Cartoon Network are cartoons.
But things that are on like the VHS tapes
that my grandma would send to me
is anime.
- Is anime.
- So, for me there was a
really clear distinction.
So like, I didn't have like
one day this sudden realization
that like oh shit "Doraemon" is an anime.
Because it was just so natural to me.
- See I don't even remember
when I got that realization.
'Cause I think I must have got it
when I properly started getting into anime
with "Naruto" was my
first like anime anime.
And that was purely because
I just kept seeing avatars
and GIFs on the internet.
And I was like this kind of
looks like "Dragon Ball Z,"
(laughing softly)
which I grew up on,
which that cartoon now I was really into.
- Do they have ridiculously spiky hair?
(laughing softly)
Yeah, probably the same thing.
- Exactly right?
- Yeah, I think because
I was on the internet
way before I started watching anime.
And I think obviously
being on the internet,
you see a lot of anime.
I was just thinking
like, what is this shit?
What I'm trying to play B.R.U.C.E Escape,
why are they talking about this stuff.
I don't get it.
All I knew is that their
opinion didn't matter
because they had anime profile pictures.
- Which I guess still is
like entertaining to say-
- It's a timeless thing.
(laughing loudly)
- That's just a meme now
it's generational now is generational.
- No man, I mean "Pokemon"
was the first one for me.
I must've been like, God.
I mean "Pokemon" was always
one of my favorite shows.
And I think we've mentioned this
in like episode zero or something,
that it had like an overarching story.
Which you only really got,
you didn't really get it actually
in any except for like "Avatar,"
but that came way later.
Like an olds '90s.
- You just called "Avatar" an anime?
- Okay like cartoon, so
I was comparing cartoon.
(laughing loudly)
- I was about to fucking.
- Because you don't watch
"Courage the Cowardly Dog"
for the overarching story, right?
- No, no.
- You watch it 'cause
every episode is great
and you have a good time.
But then I remember "Pokemon" was like,
oh, they're actually
working towards something.
- I think as well,
that era of anime as well
on like a lot of cartoons,
yes there was like episodic moments.
But as you said, there was
like an overarching story.
- Yeah, even if it was a filler,
you knew they had a goal.
And that seemed to be the case where
that kind of structure really spoke to me
as if for whatever reason.
I really enjoyed that as a kid.
And then "Yu-Gi-Oh!" had the same thing
and then I thought,
oh well what are these things
with all the spiky head people,
and they're really well-drawn things,
I like these kind of cartoons.
- It's so weird that for me
at least with "Yu-Gi-Oh!"
is that I didn't know
"Yu-Gi-Oh!" was an anime
because I grew up with
the card game first.
- Really?
- Yeah, same I got
the card game and then watch the anime.
- Yeah right?
- Everyone in your school
was playing Yu-Gi-Oh.
- Yeah.
- I didn't get that phase,
I didn't get that Yu-Gi-Oh phase.
Because when I was in school
everyone was like trading Pokemon cards,
and nobody knew how to
play the actual game.
- Oh no, no, no. No one did.
- We have like a black market
like trade deal with Pokemon cards.
(laughing loudly)
- I had a really dark Yu-Gi-Oh phase.
I was legit like fucking,
'cause my dad like used to work
for like a printing company.
So what he would do is he
would find like high res
like pictures of Exodia.
- Oh no.
- My parents
did that one time it was wrong.
- And he would print them out
and I would come to school and I'd be,
y'all I got all five pieces of Exodia
and they'd be like "a 10 year
old doesn't know, right?"
So, "they'd be like oh
no way, you got Exodia?"
But it was funny as well because like
Yu-Gi-Oh! Pokemon cards, no
one knew how to play Yu-Gi-Oh!
It was just like, "cool you have Exodia?"
- Because I feel the rules of Yu-Gi-Oh!
were easier to understand
the rules of Pokemon.
- Yeah, Pokemon was hard.
- Yeah, 'cause I don't think anyone
in my school played the Pokemon card game.
- You just collect them.
- Yeah, you just
collected them, right?
It was easy to understand you had a Shiny
and you just-
- Shahzad.
- Yeah once you get Shahzad.
- Well that's the thing though, right?
It's like in order to play
the Pokemon card games
you need it to like not
throw away the energy cards-
- Which no one wanted.
- Everybody did.
- Everybody was the
energy card and all that.
- Which like in my school like,
in my school everyone was just like
yep, go, go, go.
(laughing softly)
have and go.
- It was just collecting them.
- That's was just lunch time
everyday at my school.
But yeah,
'cause I've I started to realize
that I've really liked anime
when everyone got into Pokemon,
when we had the Pokemon
card game phase as well.
So it was just like a global craze.
- [Connor] Oh yeah.
- And that how long did that last?
That lasted like a year
or something, right?
- Well, I think-
- Or like a few months.
- The year I was born 1996,
I think Pokemon was the most
Googled thing of that year.
- Well because the game had just came out.
- Had just came out
and obviously since that point onwards
through the mid 2000s
it was pretty insane.
Pokemon was like
and arguably still today
is one of the biggest like-
- 'Cause I just kept watching "Pokemon"
even after when the craze gone.
- [Connor] Same.
- And my mum and dad wondering like,
why is this kid still into Pokemon?
(laughing loudly)
What the fuck is going on?
- I had the same thing,
my parents they were worried for me.
They were like,
do we need to like do
something about this?
Like he's still watching cartoons
and my older brother
had forgotten cartoons.
It was a sign of pride
that he'd stopped watching cartoons.
He was like,
I only watch reality TV
show now with my parents,
I don't want to watch this kid show.
- I watch MTV, but not for the music.
- Right, right.
- And I fucking loved "Samurai Jack"
like I would always try
and watch "Samurai Jack."
"Courage the Cowardly Dog" anime as well.
And my parents genuinely
were concerned for me.
I don't know if they still
are still concern for me.
(laughing loudly)
I'm watching just a little bit.
- I think much less so
now that you've made one.
- Yeah.
- That's the exact point 'cause
all the way up to university
and when I rediscovered what anime was,
my parents were like,
"He's doing it again, why?"
We thought we're past this fucking phase.
(laughing loudly)
- When they found out I was
watching more anime than ever,
they were even more concerned.
And they were like, oh he's
caught even harder into this.
We thought it would stop.
- I remember my dad,
like the funniest thing my dad ever said,
I think I was like maybe the
last year of high school.
And that was like when I was like,
this is right before I
made my YouTube channel.
And I was like watching every anime ever.
And my dad would be like,
"what are you doing in your room?"
'Cause he thought I was
doing something else.
And when I told him that
I was watching anime,
I remember my dad saying like,
"okay, at this point I think
I'd rather you just do drugs."
(laughing loudly)
It's like I would've
been less disappointed
if I found that you were
doing drugs in your room.
- Which one's more life crushing.
(laughing loudly)
- Arguably they're both around the same.
- Exactly, right?
- Yeah but like I don't know like,
I guess like,
I don't really have like a phase of like,
when I discovered anime or anything
because as long as I've known.
- I do.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Even Manga as well like,
I started reading Manga like
around the same time that
I discovered Doraemon,
which is probably around when I was like
four or five years old.
- Oh damn, so you've been
reading Manga since four or five?
- Probably, maybe earlier than that.
But I specifically remember
the first ever volume
of Manga I ever got was
volume two of "Doraemon",
I don't know why my mum didn't get me
volume one of the Doraemon,
that would've been cooler?
But I didn't know that it
was an overarching story.
So I was like, okay I'll
just start reading this,
had no idea what the fuck
was going on at first,
until I got volume one and I was like,
"oh now it makes sense."
It's like-
- Wow,
man I feel like my anime thing was like
there's three points
in my life where like,
I can very vividly
remember watching anime,
first was like "Pokemon."
And occasionally seeing a
"Yu-Gi-Oh!" episode of the cards.
But I think maybe when I
got access to the internet
I think that's when another one came,
cause I remember watching like "Yu-Gi-Oh!"
I think it was GX.
My parts, three parts.
- The three parts on YouTube.
(laughing loudly)
- You know is an OG anime fan,
because they're like,
"oh yeah don't you hate it
when you find an espanol sub
of "Yu-Gi-Oh!""
Okay, so envision it right.
It's 2000, right?
You watch episode one,
part one of "Yu-Gi-Oh!"
And you're like okay, cool.
I'm gonna watch episode one, part two.
You click it, it's the
next recommended video.
It's an espanol, what do you do?
Do you keep looking or do you just give up
and go to the next part?
I remember so many times I had to do that
and I was confused as fuck.
- You know what?
I think what's worst than that,
is when you like could
someone uploads like
a full anime movie onto YouTube,
but because it had to be
split into like eight parts
- No.
- And like always, always like
either part six or part five.
- Always one of them.
- Always fucking one part.
- There's always one part.
- There's always one part that was missing
and you couldn't find it.
So you just had to give
up and just be like,
all right I'll just skip 15 minutes
and just hopefully try and catch it.
- I think there's 15 minutes
of the first narrative movie
that I've just never seen,
because I've watched it on YouTube.
(laughing loudly)
I don't know what's happening.
It might be the best 15 minutes
of narrative of the story.
(laughing loudly)
I don't fucking know,
'cause I haven't seen it.
- What was it?
It's like the max upload
time was 10 minutes
on YouTube right before.
- 10 yeah.
- Yeah, so that's why it split into three.
And I remember that was like
one of the biggest phases of me.
- And the third part would always just be
five minutes or something.
(laughing loudly)
- There was the outro
whose half off of it.
Oh man yeah,
that was definitely a big phase for me.
And I could have been
around 13, 14 at that point.
- Question to you then
did you grow up during
the "Toonami" phase?
Because I feel like "Toonami"
has played such a big factor
into making the anime fans of today.
- No, for some reason,
did we have "Toonami" in the UK?
[Joey]We did.
- We did, but you needed Sky TV.
So you needed Cartoon Network,
to be able to watch "Toonami."
- So Sky is basically cable in the UK.
- Wait, you guys didn't get
Cartoon Network just free to you.
- No, no, no.
- No, no, no,
you had to pay for Carton Network.
- Really, 'cause I'm pretty
sure in Australia was free-
- Oh wow yeah,
'cause I remember my parents paid,
'cause my dad wanted to pay
for the football matches in the UK
and you basically got the whole bundle.
So I would watch the cartoon stuff.
And I remember there
was loads of cartoons.
I never saw anime.
I think it was airing really late.
And by then my parents were like,
"why aren't you in bed son?
What are doing?"
- 'Cause what was on "Toonami."
- It was like "Dragon Ball Z,
" Gundam Wing."
- I remember seeing "Dragon Ball."
Never watched it there,
cause it was always a mess
Cause they had it out of order.
So I didn't know what was going on.
So I thought it was cool,
but I couldn't get into it.
- Yeah, I think "Dragon Ball Z"
and "Gundam Wing" were the only two
I was able to watch whenever,
cause our family didn't have Sky TV.
So I could only watch it when
I go to my cousin's house
and I'll be watching
episodes out of order.
"Gundam Wing" made no fucking sense to me.
- "Gundam Wing" still makes no sense.
(laughing loudly)
- Yeah, you can watch
"Gundam Wing" all day
and it will still make no sense.
(laughing loudly)
- Like I'll be watching a scene
and for some reason the
guy wants to kill this girl
but the girl still wants
to get with the guy,
makes no fucking sense to me as a kid.
"Gundam Wing" already
confusing enough as it is,
"Dragon Ball Z" was okay,
because I could skip five episodes
and they'd be still-
- It'd still the same fight.
- It'd be still the same fight, you know.
- Goku would just be like
three steps closer to Frieza.
(laughing softly)
- Cause I remember like,
I would have to be watching
these scenes in "Dragon Ball Z."
- And Goku was like
powering up the spirit bomb.
And then I'd not be
able to go to my cousins
till like two weeks later.
Then Goku was still
powering that spirit bomb.
(laughing loudly)
So, I was like this is
just the next episode.
No, it was like I missed
three four episodes
and it was just still the same shit.
- And to this day he's
still powering it up.
Still hasn't finished, man.
- If he hasn't died for the seven times.
Come back to life.
- Because my exposure
to anime has got like
now that I think back to it,
there's the main phases of
like the "Pokemon" phase.
And then there's the "Toonami" phase.
Well, I'd see it on Toonami and TV.
And then there was this huge gap.
- I have the exact same thing.
- And then like I realized
now that in this huge gap,
I still had like small exposures to anime.
Like whenever I go to
Thailand we'd always have
these shitty Thai dubs,
(laughing loudly)
like "Ultraman" was like
a massive in Thailand
even though that's not an anime,
but we'd have like "Dragon Ball Z" dubs
and man having listening to Thai dubs,
they've already got five
voice actors and actresses
and they voiced every
character in every anime.
- I respect it, I respect it.
- We got to play it for the audience
(laughing loudly)
I just want to hear it.
- Anyone whose grown up in Southeast Asia
knows what I'm talking about.
When you have five voice actors
who plays every character in every show.
And then my cousin showed me,
I think it was "Princess
Mononoke," just as it came out.
I didn't know it was anime Just like,
was this animated film.
I thought it was Disney.
- How old are you when you
watch "Princess Mononoke?"
- I mean it came out in '97.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so I must've been
it was the year after it came out,
cause it was out on DVD.
- It's pretty gruesome
movie to watch, it like...
(laughing softly).
- Yeah, yeah.
- That was the first movie I watched.
- I thought that movie was just Disney.
And then just,
(laughing loudly)
before I discovered narrative
and everything like that,
I went through the LimeWire phase.
- Yeah.
- I had that.
It was just from music though.
I didn't, I don't know-
- No, just for music,
same era.
So I would be browsing LimeWire for music,
I probably would like
downloading Linkin Park
or Papa Roach or something like that.
- As you do in 2004.
- As you do in 2004
and then something else like,
you know sometimes you download a file
and it's not the file you aim for, like-
- It's like you mean
very file in LimeWire.
- The Bill Clinton file like-
- Bill Clinton file.
- Oh my God.
- Oh my God, so good.
- So, in LimeWire someone
was just circulating
Bible Black clips.
(laughing softly)
- The dub.
- Yeah the dub, it was the dubbed as well.
(laughing loudly)
I never knew that Bible
Black was a Japanese anime.
Cause I'm just like,
what is this shitty
porn that I'm watching.
As a kid I'm like,-
- Yeah, it's kinda hot though.
- Holy fuck, this is fucking amazing!
(laughing loudly)
- That's exactly how AKI
discovered it as well.
- Yeah.
- She said in multiple videos
that going through LimeWire
obviously looking for the
new Linkin Park album.
- I mean you just trust people, right?
- And it was the technical
scene of Bible Black.
And she's like,
this is like she had like an epiphany.
She was like, "This is the
most amazing thing ever."
I can imagine though, like
because I don't even remember.
I don't want to get onto the topic
but like I don't remember
how I discovered that site.
- People are like get on
the topic, get on the topic.
(laughing loudly)
- Because I didn't I obviously
didn't know it was hentai
or I didn't even know it was anime.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- But holy shit I'm having a
fucking epiphany right now.
(laughing softly)
"Bible Black" wasn't the only
hentai I downloaded on there.
(laughing loudly)
- What else?
- Oh my God,
cause I remember downloading full length
and "Hansei", that came out in the '90s.
I can't remember the name, but I-
- Why are you downloading
a full length hentai pal?
- Because I like you said,
you're just downloading random files.
And I got one of these
files that I downloaded
was this hentai that I
can't remember the title,
had angel in the name.
There's a lot of '90s-
- In a million, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- It had an angel on the name, I'm like,
what if I just put this
title into LimeWire
and see what comes up?
And there were like six
titles that came up.
So as a kid, I'm like-
- I'll download all of them.
- I'm downloading all of these.
(laughing loudly)
- How to destroy your laptop, speed run.
Did you ruin any laptops or PCs?
- Oh fuck yeah.
- Yeah, I blamed it on my brother
and he totally
got blamed for it, but it was
totally me the first time.
- I couldn't blame it on anyone
cause I'm the oldest in the family so.
(laughing loudly)
- I think the reason why
and I just realized this now
I was just wondering
what the fuck was I doing
between like 13 and 18?
I couldn't think about it.
And I just realized,
I was cripplingly like addicted to Xbox.
It was like every second I got free.
I was playing Call Of Duty.
That was like-
Cause as you're with your
friends as well, right?
And that's the golden
age of playing games,
where you have to play with
your friends after school.
It was like immediately when I was done,
I'd go home play games
until I had to go to bed.
- And that was like the
golden age of card as well.
- Oh my God, that was perfect, yeah.
- Like Modern Warfare two.
- Modern Warfare two
came out when I was like 15, 16,
which is like the perfect time to play it.
- I think I had an age like,
a gap as well that I didn't watch anime
and it was around the same time.
I know exactly why I wasn't
but I'm not gonna say
it cause it's probably
not appropriate for YouTube.
(laughing softly)
- Oh god.
But you can take a guess
to what that might be.
But weirdly enough, even
though like during that gap
until like probably the
last year of high school,
I was still reading Mongo religiously.
Yeah, so I don't know what it is,
it's like I had this burnout with anime
or maybe just like a loss
of interest with anime.
But for some reason,
Mongo was always one thing
that I would just come home
and just read the shit out of.
- Which is a little more engaging almost
you have to like actively make an effort.
- Probably.
And also because I was just
like reading in general, I think so.
- So I mean the question to you guys,
what drew you to anime over
like cartoons or other things,
Like what drew you to
this medium specifically?
- As a child or like-
- As a kid
and growing up as well?
- For me, it was just the fact
that my mom would just push it a lot
because she knew that it was
the easiest way for me
to keep my Japanese.
- Appreciate the Japanese culture, yeah.
- God, I'm just fucking jealous.
(laughing loudly)
- Yeah and so,
every time I realize Joey was
born on Japanese household,
speaks Japanese, God I...
- My mom knew that
if I just kept talking to her in Japanese,
it would most likely stick,
but she wanted me to like not
just be competent in Japanese.
- Like appreciate the whole culture.
- Really like,
not just appreciate the culture,
but also excel in Japanese.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And like thank God
because now I think I have.
And like you know,
I have learnt like appreciate the culture
and just anime in
general and the language.
And like, I did like you know
learn fucked up of Japanese.
Even though I say it in a lot of videos,
don't use anime to learn Japanese.
I kind of admit
I learned a lot of Japanese
from watching anime.
- I mean any amount of language
that you take in to learn,
like if you're watching anything
in a language it's good,
you know it'll help.
Is it the best way?
- I feel Like,
as a kid, you just
absorb it through osmosis
or something like like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- I remember learning Thai
just because whenever I'd go to Thailand,
I would just absorb it,
whenever I was talking to my family
or just watching TV shows.
- Did you learn any Thai from Thai dub?
(laughing loudly)
- I'd love to hear a comic in Thai.
(laughing softly)
- It's probably the same, right?
- You know it's the same.
- [Connor] Okay, okay.
- It's the same.
It's just very bad quality.
(laughing loudly)
It's kind of like,
I don't know, there wasn't a lot of money
put into the dubbing industry
I reckon, so-
- Back then as well.
- Exactly.
- Still not that much to your fact.
- Yeah, that should be true.
- We all learn in our
second language then purely
because we were just raised in
an area where it was spoken.
But the thing is,
well when you were a kid you know,
you have way more time to just sit there
and absorb it when you're an adult,
I get 10 minutes a day on Jeweling
well, maybe right?
- Yeah.
- Whereas a kid it's like eight hours
of just you're hearing this stuff.
So obviously you're gonna pick it up.
- Right.
- I mean that was just
from as far as I can
remember with my childhood
like the only memories I have
is just like either watching anime,
reading Mongo or like
watching cosmic books.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah
- So, already just from that
like two thirds of my
childhood essentially
is me just absorbing the Japanese language
in any way possible.
So, I think that just helped me...
If I never got into anime or Mongo,
I would like to think that I would be
nowhere near as good at
the language as I am now.
- I think definitely for me
when I was watching anime
the thing that appealed to me
especially my younger age is that,
like I said earlier like there's
more of a structure, right?
And there's always an
overarching like point,
and there's normally a journey to go on.
And also I felt like, you know I mean,
this wasn't a problem back
then when with all cartoons,
you know the ones that
we grew up with, but.
I felt like anime didn't
treat the audience stupid.
- No, no, no.
You know like if you're like 16, 18.
Maybe you don't want to watch "Pokemon"
but you can still
appreciate it and enjoy it.
- Right, right, right.
- And I felt that some cartoons,
I mean, you can watch
"Samurai Jack" any age, right?
It's time, it's part-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- There was a lot,
when I was growing up the very
treated you as a kid, right?
- Mmh.
Whereas "Pokemon" was
like, "you're a teenager,
you're going on the journey,
you can catch Pokemon."
And it was so cool to
imagine yourself as that.
Like it sounds dumb, but-
- How old was Ash again?
- 10.
- Ash 10, but I mean he
had his shit together
for a 10 year old right?
- No, he did.
- Yeah and Brock is like 35 or something.
- Right.
- I'm like,
why is he hanging with this kid,
like what the fuck?
- Like you imagine a mom
just letting a 10 year old go
into the fucking world by
himself with a fucking rat
to keep him company.
- I mean, wasn't the whole joke
that like the mom sent her also
that she can like have a
family with professor Oak,
wasn't that the whole thing?
- Brock commits crimes and like,
yeah I guess that was
really irresponsible of us
to let him go with a 45 year old man.
- And how is Misty okay with like
Ash hanging out with this 10 year old kid
like throws your bike into a river.
And he's like, "I'll pay you back."
- How also as like a 10 year old Ash,
do you have any concept
of Brock constantly hitting on people?
How do you like perceive that?
Like what does that to
you as a 10 year old.
- Imagine being Brock and
just leaving your family
and your job to like
follow this 10 year old.
- He just totally ditch his job,
that is so irresponsible.
- Remember he missed Illa.
He had a massive family as well.
(laughing loudly)
like what the fuck are you doing Brock?
He had like 10 brothers and sisters,
what are you doing?
- Needless to say that
kind of reckless behavior
really appealed to me as a kid, you know.
(laughing softly)
I'm just often leaving my family
that I was supporting with my job.
- Leaving my family for what?
To follow this ten-year-old
so I can go slay some posts.
(laughing loudly)
- It's like strangely
reminiscent of like "Hisoka"
from hunt to hunter.
It's like grown man just
wants to follow a kid around
and see him grow.
- The biggest thing for
me though with "Pokemon"
that just made no sense to me,
is how Gary Oak is like
essentially the same age as Ash,
And yet he can get like all these pus.
- Is it bad that I actually
liked Garry more than Ash
and I loved it when he was a dick to Ash.
I'm like, yeah, you should
be catching Pokemon Ash.
- Because he was actually
achieving the goal
of trying to become a Pokemon master.
- You know what?
I feel like as a kid,
maybe you appreciate Ash more,
but as an adult you're like,
"Gary is kind of got his shit together."
(laughing loudly)
Like Gary's achieving his dream.
- No, no.
- Yeah.
Yeah, it was cool that
you saved that Butterfree
and reunited it with Ash.
But like-
- But Gary has 10 bags,
there are not even 10 bags in the game.
- Did Butterfree start a
patron to pay your bills?
No he didn't, go and get a job Ash.
- Gary's on like a gold split speed
running this entire shit.
(laughing loudly)
- He was doing 80% Pokemon,
if most speed was a thing.
(laughing loudly)
- 80% it like getting all the pussies.
You're just doing it all.
That man did it all like.
And yet we still we're
supposed to hate him.
Like are you okay?
- [Joey] You got to fucking
cheerleaders with him as well.
(laughing loudly)
- [Anime Zone] Oh, my God.
- I remember there was one episode
like I think when they were like
when Ash was about to
like go to Kyogre I think,
- Yeah.
- And Gary just rocks up
in a fucking like..
- [Connor] Lamborghini.
- Lamborghini.
(laughing loudly)
With like 10 chicks just to be like,
"you're still here?
I already got all the badges."
cause I'm just like
"who's driving the car?"
(laughing loudly)
- Yeah, not only is he
an expert Pokemon master.
He's a logistic expert.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Getting all these women around,
always in his Lamborghini,
but he doesn't worry about
parking tickets, come on.
I mean like, Ash is walking everywhere.
(laughing loudly)
Point being I think Ash's kind of shitty.
- Yeah.
- I mean, yeah definitely as a kid,
that whole kind of structure
and the kind of you know,
going on a journey I was like.
Did you guys feel really disappointed
when Ash got beaten in the Pokemon?
- [Joey And Anime Zone] Yeah.
- I was like,
this is our destiny.
He formed these artificial
bonds with these Pokemon,
and fucking Shahzad had the balls to sleep
at the final fight.
Are you serious Shahzad?
- As a kid, it was like
top 10 anime twist of all.
- [Connor] Yeah, it was-
- Top 10 anime twist
at all time.
- All time.
- Shahzad he saved you bro,
he saved you help him please
(laughing softly).
- There's actually this really funny thing
I've found the other day
when I was looking at the
like "Pokemon" speed runs.
You know, there's a
thing called Ash percent.
(laughing loudly)
- I think I yeah I saw that.
- Where you have
to play the game exactly,
like catch every Pokemon
exactly the same as Ash did.
- Oh my God.
- You have to release your Butterfree,
you have to release your Charizard,
and then you have to
purposely lose at the-
(laughing loudly)
- That would drive me mental man.
- I know (laughing softly).
- Oh my God.
- It's like shirtless Mario speed run,
on Super Mario Odyssey.
- [Joey] Odyssey.
- Yeah you basically just do a speed run
on Super Mario Odyssey.
Where you try and get Mario
shirtless quick as possible.
- Yeah Nipple percent, it's the best.
- I love the troll speed runs.
- Anyway, we got off topic.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, okay and I don't know,
was it the same thing as
well for you as a kid?
- Yeah like, I don't know,
I couldn't quite put my finger on it,
but it was this huge overarching plots.
Like they had a goal and they
were working towards a goal.
Like "Pokemon" turned out to me,
as I watched more anime
I started liking "Pokemon" less and less.
Like when I see things
like "Digimon" came out
and they had an actual like story arc
instead of being cut by Charizard.
(laughing loudly)
at the most crucial moment.
"Digimon" for me was probably
the moment when I actually
fell in love with anime.
- Yeah.
- You wanna know something?
I never watched the "Digimon" anime.
- Did you not?
- I watched it.
- Anything "Digimon" that I ever consumed
are the two movies.
- I played the games as well as a kid.
And the only thing I remember
is them being hot as fuck.
- Oh, they are.
- There are games with that?
- There's games and I think at
least the Digimon world games
I don't know how old they are.
I remember some of the
hardest games to get
full completion of any games ever.
Like they're like insane.
And I remember as a kid thinking like,
"what the fuck, why can't
I get past the first level?
I beat all the Pokemon in French.
what the hell like?"
- Yeah I never,
I don't know what it is,
maybe because I was just
so obsessed with "Pokemon."
But I always knew "Digimon" was a thing.
But I never watched any of-
- It was always the joke as a kid, right?
You were like the fucking comedian
if you were like,
"I guess you're the Digimon."
(laughing softly)
You know what I mean?
- You're the Digimon kid.
- Yeah.
(laughing loudly)
- No one want's to be the Digimon kid.
- I have a question for you specifically.
- Okay.
- Cause obviously this
doesn't apply to you,
but did you as a kid have a sense of like,
I kind of liked this whole
like Japanese culture thing.
Whenever it propped up,
in like TV or anything.
- I mean to me it was less exotic.
'cause to me it was Asian culture.
- [Connor] I guess, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, because I had seen more of it
'cause I didn't exactly
grow up in Thailand
but I would visit there
at least once a year.
So I'd spend like my summer
holidays in Thailand every year.
So, seeing some of the
more Japanese culture
or the more Asian oriented culture,
it's not that different from what you get
from flying to Asia.
Like Japanese specific, like say onigiri
I had no idea what the fuck-
- Onigiri donuts.
(laughing softly)
- Yeah, onigiri donuts,
but I could see that,
it was just a ball of rice.
I know what rice is, I
can see what this is.
- I guess that's the
difference of me coming from,
the whitest place on earth.
(laughing loudly)
And not being exposed to any other,
especially Asian cultures.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The only Asian exposure I had,
apart from media, it was just like
the shitty Chinese stuff,
that you know down the road
we've had awful Chinese.
And so I think whenever
I saw Japanese stuff
in media I thought it was so cool.
It's gonna sound so fucking
dumb that I will say this,
- Go on.
- Do you remember
"Jackass:The Movie" or whatever?
Where one of them goes to Japan
and it's all just stripping
in a store and dancing.
- Yeah.
- The whole time, I just ignore that.
I was like, dude look at
those fucking appliances,
they're having.
I thought it was so cool,
they had all these appliances in the store
that I have never seen them.
Because in the West we never got those
TV and radio built-in things.
And they had the numbers on the side.
I thought those were
cool as as fuck as a kid.
And then obviously watching
like Samurai stuff.
And then "Samurai Jack" was a
huge thing that made me think
I fucking love Samurai's as a kid.
They were like they were like
the coolest things to me.
- I think it was either,
depending on if you
were into anime or not.
The two things that
got people into Samurai
were at the "Samurai Jack"
or "The Last Samurai"
- I can still watch
"Samurai Jack" today and
like fucking love everything.
- Dude the newest season
was fucking awesome.
- Oh my God the fuck
make you cry like a baby.
- "Samurai Jack" is just a fucking
great show period.
- Amazing, yeah.
- "Samurai Jack" was like
the one Cartoon Network show
other than "Ed Edd n Eddy"
that my dad would be just
as excited to watch with me.
- It was so good.
- It was like,
dude, "Samurai Jack" is
on move out of the way.
- I remember the episode
with like the assassin.
Do you remember this one?
He had the robot dog.
I love that episode.
- [Joey And Anime Zone] Yeah, yeah.
- That's one of my favorites.
But I think in my head looking back now
I feel like it was inevitable
that I was gonna get into anime.
'Cause I had a fondness
for Japanese culture.
Well it wasn't like intense
or weepy or anything.
I liked the movies, I liked
all the culture that I saw.
I loved video games and
being a video game fan.
You're gonna run into
stuff so you're like,
huh, why is it like this?
And you're like, oh it's Japanese.
And then also watching anime
from a young age and like.
So I felt like it was
inevitable at some point
in my life I was gonna find anime
and be like I fucking love this shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause I feel like
I completely forgot about video games
and just JRPGs in general.
- It's a big push,
you don't realize how
much you're like pushing.
- Exactly, and I realized a
lot of the same story tropes
that drew me to anime,
like I liked in JRPGs
and that's why I really
get into JRPGs as well.
I guess,
do you remember the time
when Japan just felt
like this foreign concept?
- Oh, yeah (laughing softly).
- This is way past even
when me discovering anime.
But I remember after discovering anime
I started discovering
narrative and everything,
it was so weird to find
anyone who went to Japan
or see any kind of like Japanese media,
even outside of the Japan.
- I feel like it's only recently
become a tourist destination.
- [Anime Zone] Yeah.
- [Joey] Definitely yeah.
- If my parents who never
wanna leave Europe, right?
They're like, if it's not
Europe, it's not a vacation.
If they're considering
career in Japan sounds cool.
If that don't like that,
I'm like, okay
well now I guess everyone's up to it now.
- Are they thinking that?
- Yeah, they were planning
not just 'cause I lived here,
but they wanna come anyway.
- Oh okay.
- And yeah I feel like there's
that kind of mainstreamness of it anyways
is really had a big impact recently.
'Cause I remember when I first started
watching stuff on YouTube,
there was no like vloggers.
- [Joey] No.
- [Anime Zone] No.
- Except for like,
I remember watching a Chris Broad video
from like years ago.
And he was like the only guy, right?
- He was one of the OGs.
- Right.
- I'd like to think, yeah.
- And I remember back then
if you wanted to find
something in Japanese
it would have to be
like a BBC documentary.
Someone going there, right?
- [Joey And Anime Zone] Yeah.
- It was not a YouTube thing.
- The weird working world of Japan.
- Right, whereas now
you can find out anything
you want about this country.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- It's not hard,
but I remember yeah, like same thing
I had no fucking clue.
- You'd see,
these weird commercials.
You'd see these clips
from these talk shows
or the variety shows.
And you're like, what the fuck
is going on in this country?
I have no idea.
- I mean there was like that
giant "Takeshi's Castle."
- I totally forgot that.
- I forgot about that.
- "Takeshi's Castle" at 7:00
a.m. every day on challenge.
And I used to wake up early before school
and I would like watch every episode.
- I didn't think you
guys get this excited.
(laughing loudly)
- I just totally glossed over it.
I literally watched "Takeshi's castle"
all throughout high school.
- You know what same here.
- Even though it's reruns.
I fucking loved it every time.
- Yeah, you just watch the
same episodes over and over.
It's like watching "Top Gear" on Dave,
it's something you can
always watch over and over
and it was just so fucking weird-
- It's recently that I found out though
that like "Takeshi's castle",
you guys had reruns
with "Takeshi's Castle?"
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I found that
really interesting because
that's a show from the '80s.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's strange
'cause I think America has
their own version as well.
But like "Takeshi's
Castle" is this kind of,
what is it called?
The most extreme game show is it called-
- Pretty much, it's like "Ninja Warrior,"
something like that.
That's like the modern anime-
- It's like "Ninja warrior,"
but imagine if it was like,
all the contestants were
just everyday people
and it was horribly
unfair, it was so unfair
and it was so fun and it was just brutal.
These courses they would just send people
and they would all fail.
- Especially "Ninja Warrior"
across the Jackass.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it looked dangerous.
Some of the courses look
so fucking dangerous.
- I mean there's a reason why
they don't do that show anymore.
- No, no, no.
- Because it's like
legit OHNS.
- Yeah.
- That show had a huge following
in the UK because of that.
And I think in America did as well,
but each localization had
a different style to it.
So, the Japanese
obviously showed the show,
the British one had like this-
- Craig Charles.
- Craig Charles who's
quite a famous person
back in the '90s, right.
- Because he did "Robot Wars" and-
- Right, right, and.
- Yeah.
- It was really big and in
America they had a kind of
imagine a pseudo kind
of football commentators
being like, what do
you think of that Jeff?
It was supposed to be
kind of like jokey things,
I actually watched clips of it.
I don't think it's as good,
but each country got its own localization.
And the one that UK was huge,
'cause I remember there was petitions
even when I was like 16, 17.
People wanting to bring it back.
But I mean, how can you bring it back when
they're just dubbing over the old clips.
But Thailand actually had,
I think a version like
a few years ago as well.
- Did they?
- They made their own version.
- I have no fucking a clue.
- 'Cause I remember watching
and thinking like, nope, not the same.
I just didn't think, quite catch it,
but that was a huge factor
in why also I love Japanese culture
'cause you watch that show and like-
- It's crazy.
- It's hilarious.
- It's amazing and it's also a blatantly,
extremely Japanese.
- Yeah.
- You're seeing Katakana Kanji everywhere.
It's purely Japanse.
- It's like '80 HD, like
editing, you know anime.
- It's pure,
yeah that was my first introduction
to like crazy Japanese.
- Yeah.
- It's pure chaos, I don't know
what it is about Japanese variety shows,
it's just about having as
much information on screen
to distract your eyes as possible.
- After making YouTube videos.
I've come to feel sorry
for every Japanese editor.
With the sheer amount of texts
they have to put on the screen.
Changing colors and shit
popping up everywhere.
- Because everybody's
dialogue has subtitles.
(laughing lightly)
And it's like we can hear them fine.
Don't worry about it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you know what I hate?
Whenever I see an anime trailer
and it's from Japanese TV.
So they always got this guy reacting to it
or something like that.
- In the corner right?
(laughing loudly)
And then not even reacting that much.
They're just like.
- Yeah, that's the thing that
Jordan said about game shows.
They'll have a really normal thing
and they'll have a guy in the corner like.
(laughing softly)
- It was like a really
interesting behind the scenes clip
of this anime or show
I remember seeing the journal
clip of the guy doing MOODA.
- Yeah.
- Right.
And it's just the guy
reacting in the corner.
I was like I don't give
a shit about that guy.
- Yeah.
- Taking a valuable screen.
- Yeah I know, just
let me see the fucking-
- I wanna watch the guy doing the MOODA.
(laughing loudly)
I mean, I have to say that
with "Takeshi's Castle,"
I fucking loved growing
up while watching it.
- Oh my God, what a show.
- What was your guys'
favorite segment of that show?
Because for me to this
day if I have a bad day,
I'll always watch clips
of Lotion Staircase.
- See, I think they have different names
to that in UK challenges.
- [Joey And Anime Zone] Yeah.
- 'Cause it was title screens.
You could tell that they
cast tried to mimic.
- I mean did you guys watch
like the Lotion Staircase one?
It's like a giant staircase
and it's just covered in lotion.
And they have to try
and get to the top of it.
- Yeah, I remember that one.
- I liked the one that they would
the Honeycomb Maze, like the Hexagon Maze.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- It was basically this maze
and you got a up top-down view,
which is so good.
And you would see them
go through this maze
and they're basically these fucking dudes
which grab them in the face,
and throw them around
and I'm like, what the fuck?
And then there's also the rolling things
that they would try and run
on, that looked impossible.
- The one, that sticks out to my mind
is the one where they're rock skipping.
Like just like
- That was dangerous.
- You fucking go full
pelt over these like rocks
over a river, and some of
the rocks would just sink.
- Ye
- Now just imagine if like
you're running full pelts
and then one of the rocks
sinks and you just face bonds
into a real rock.
Oh my God, that looks painful.
- If you haven't watched it
you're in for a treat.
It's just so good, it's such good fun.
I don't think a show like
that could happen today.
- No, no and like and it's
not just "Takeshi's Castle"
they were like I've realized there's
so many shows that
either America or the UK
or like just some Western country is like,
"Silent Library."
- And like "Wipeout"
and even like "Ninja Warrior,"
they're all like originally Japanese show.
- I love "Ninja Warrior,"
watching the Japanese version.
- They could never go as
crazy as the Japanese version.
- No, no.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah, it's crazy.
I mean, I think that was
definitely game shares.
Everything kind of got
me into anime, right.
It was just that kind of buildup of
I kind of think this culture
is kind of sick, right?
I mean I like what they do.
I like all the media that they put out
it just jives with me, right.
And I just seem to enjoy it.
And then I remember the
first anime anime, right.
This is what we're talking about.
Like finally getting into like
the shit, right?
- Modern days.
- Like real shit.
- Yeah.
- I remember, I really, for
some reason I wanted to be
like a TV and film snob.
I don't know why, I wanted to be like
I've seen everything, you know like.
- Did you go through
the IMDb top 100 phase?
- Yeah.
- I think, I feel
everyone's gone to this point.
- Yeah.
- Everyone in uni.
Everyone at uni.
I feel like uni was a big.
- It was in the,
'cause I just finished watching
"24" and "Prison Break"
and I was feeling like, man
I'm such a TV connoisseur.
I've watched "Prison Break" and "24."
So, I went through the list
and "Death Note" was like
eighth or something at the time.
- Oh my God.
- Wow.
- This must've been like 2012, 13.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And I skipped it initially.
'Cause I'm like, I don't
watch them cartoons.
I'm a grown ass man, I grew up..
- I want some real show.
- 'Cause again
my parents and all my family
and cousins and whatever
they were telling me dude
stop watching cartoons, right?
You're an adult, right?
So, I naturally skipped it.
But for some reason I did
a double take like two
or three weeks later, read
the synopsis and I thought,
okay this sounds pretty
fucking sick actually.
- Yeah.
- And if it's in the top 10,
it's got to be pretty good, right?
- Yeah.
- Watched one episode.
I had to school the next day
but I stayed up the whole
night up until school.
I had to leave with two
episodes left to watch.
So, I binged it the whole
season of "Death Note,"
in one night and oh my God,
I just immediately like became obsessed.
It was like overnight,
all my other plans to watch
all these famous movies
and TV shows get that outta here.
Someone on YouTube said
watch "Code Geass,"
so I'm gonna do that now.
(laughing lightly)
And it's just obviously that
phase where you discover
all the golden anime.
It's just like banger after banger.
And it's like three months straight
where you're just like
all you think about is
watching the next anime.
- Good.
Like remember that phase,
I've even missed that phase so much.
Everything's you've watched was amazing.
I look back at some of the shit now, like-
- [Connor] Even the shitty stuff.
- Even the shitty like I
remember going through this phase
when I was obsessed with Love Hina right?
(laughing loudly)
- I think everyone had
that phase back in the day.
- Okay, if we all have
that phase back in the day
can I ask what was the show
that ruined that for you?
Do you remember?
'Cause I knew exactly what it was for me.
- No because I feel like once
you watched enough anime,
you start like,
do you remember the
feeling of the void, right.
The void where you watch
this really, really good show
and you're like no one's gonna top this.
Nothing's gonna top this
and you just feel empty.
- And then you hit your boom woo.
(laughing lightly)
- Come on.
(laughING loudly)
- And then the more shows you watch
the more that void shrinks.
- [Connor] Right.
- Till you find the next amazing show.
And then you were like,
and then you watch enough.
And then you find your
top 10 favorite shows.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then that's
kind of when it starts cementing for me
to the next phase where
you start watching stuff
and it's not as good a feeling
as when you first started.
So, what was it for you then?
- "School Days."
(laughing loudly)
'Cause I distinctly remember this
and I remember being
really annoyed about it.
And I'm not saying that for
the meme is totally accurate.
' Cause-
- Why can I never
escape "School Days."
- Okay, you wanna know
what's even worse, right?
Is that, so I was watching anime
on YouTube still at this point, right?
So, and I remember, 'cause
I would got my anime list.
'Cause that's what everyone did, right?
You would look at which
ones are high rated
and which ones you know.
For some reason School Days
was like one of the highest rated.
(laughing loudly)
But it was split right,
it was either a 10 or a two.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I thought
I'm gonna be in the 10 categories.
- [Joey] Yeah
- Everything I've watched
so far I fucking love, right.
So, first off I already had a bad start
watching School Days because
I remember watching "School
Days HQ" or something.
And it was like-
- well, like a spinoff.
- It was like 40 minutes.
- No, no, no.
"School Days HQ" to explain
is the original visual
novel of "School days."
But the original visual
novel of School Days
was basically just a full on anime.
- Yeah.
- Right, it was all animated.
- Okay.
- I didn't know that
I was the first time
I just found that out.
- So you can watch all
the "School Days HQ"
on something like Pornhub or X videos,
which if you're ready to just like-
- X Hamsters.
(laughing loudly)
- If you're really just looking to watch
the clips that you're looking for,
you can just find it over there.
- And they would have
showed the clips in that.
I didn't get that far.
I got about, cause it was
a 40-minute episode one.
And I watched 40 minutes
and I was like, this doesn't seem right.
Am I watching the right thing?
Everyone's saying it's
good, like is this, right?
- It's so funny that you say it like
the School Days is like mal
is either like a 10 or a two.
I was definitely one of those
people who put it as a 10.
- I know you did you piece of shit,
'Cause,
I know exactly what my-
- What is going on here.
- I know what mindset you were in,
where you were like,
I'm in the fucking hood.
I gotta say yes.
- What is going on?
(laughing loudly)
Why am I sitting next to someone
who gave School Days a 10.
(laughing loudly)
- Okay look.
- Is that sheep, right.
Who everyone else has set it at 10.
And he doesn't wanna be
that one guy who was like
I don't think I have good taste.
No, I have good tastes,
I can appreciate it.
- Because for me, right, School Days
was-
- [Connor] Garbage.
- it was crap until the last episode.
Because the last episode I was like,
first of all I remember
just sitting there.
We're obviously not gonna say it
but I'm sure there's
lots of people who know-
(Connor humming)
- If you don't know at the
end of the "School Days."
Boat couldn't comes out, right.
But like School Days
for me, that ending was
the most satisfying thing
I'd ever seen in anime.
- Okay, I will give you that.
It was satisfying, but then I remembered,
I just sat through 11 of the
most boring shit in my life.
And I don't think this is
big enough to redeem it.
- Yeah, the first 11
episodes was just like
I think I need anger
management, right now.
(laughing loudly)
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Because oh my God.
I hate the main character so much.
- Oh my God, I hated him.
- And then the fucking orgasm,
you've got at episode 12
where what happened, happens.
And you're like,
oh thank God.
- That ending for me made it a 10.
- No.
- No, no.
- I was like for me-
- No.
- I specifically remember I'm like
I'm glad I went through those 11 episodes.
'Cause the I got to watch
the most satisfying ending,
I've ever seen.
- That's bullshit.
That's recency bias, right?
'Cause you're basing your
review of how it ended.
Not the fucking, the absolute shit truck
that you have to like
shovel through to get that.
- Okay, no, but here's the thing, right?
I've said this so many times in videos,
but the ending for me
is so fucking important
because like I had the exact opposite.
- 'Cause you got that goldfish brain,
the ones that tunes everything out before-
- Because I have the
exact opposite experience
with "Deadman Wonderland."
- No, I still liked that
"Deadman Wonderland."
- Because "Deadman Wonderland"
for me was amazing first 10 episodes
and the ending was just the most garbage,
bullshit like okay, we
ran out of budget ending
that I've ever seen.
That it just completely
ruin the experience.
- But that doesn't mean it's a one.
- I'm not putting, no, no.
- I mean, it means.
- I didn't put "Deadman
Wonderland" like a one-
- What did you give "Deadman Wonderland?"
- The anime?
- Yeah.
- Like a five.
- What no, no,
it's better than a five.
- Because then I read the
"Monga" and the "Monga"
is infinitely better.
- You think so?
- Yeah.
- I thought where the "Monga."
- Because the "Monga" actually ends.
I like the fucking anime.
- Do you like the ending
of the "Monga" though?
- It's better than the fucking anime.
- I guess, I remember
reading "Deadman Wonderland."
And I kind of liked
what it did a little bit
but the ending, I wasn't too
big of a fan over the "Monga."
- Right, but I enjoyed it
even if it was just like
a mediocre ending, right.
- [Connor] At least you got an ending.
- At least I got an okay ending.
Whereas the anime just
left me wanting more
and I'm like don't cock tease me like that
after the 10 amazing episodes.
- But would you rather a show that has
like 10 amazing episodes with no ending
or 24 episodes with 10 amazing episodes.
And it starts to go kind of man
the ending's a little questionable.
- The first.
- I think this
is what we got with Deadman there.
- Yeah.
- We got 10 bangers, and then.
- That's why like-
- But I'm just trying
to wrap my head around
how he could justify the "School Days."
- Okay let me.
- I've just been
sitting here for the past few minutes
having a fucking mental
breakdown by myself.
- Let me rephrase, let me rephrase, okay.
I had so many opinion changes
on the ending of the "School
Days," so many times.
- Okay, so what would you
give School Days now then?
- Now I would give it a six.
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
- No, no, no, no,
my gosh man.
- I had a phase where I'm
like, is this ending genius
or is it the worst garbage
I've ever seen?
- It's not genius.
- If I make a character that is so
fucking appealing and then I kill him off.
You shouldn't be-
- He's not even a
good character, he's not a good character.
- But that's exactly the reason why
the ending is satisfying.
- No, but it's satisfying,
but it's just so fucking surface level.
You know what I mean?
- I mean, I wouldn't
watch it again.
- 'Cause
this protagonist, it's
the one that we follow.
He made this character
dog shit on purpose.
But then there's also a
little bits where he tries to
make you like the guy and
that's the worst part.
And that's what I fucking hate,
it's like, no, don't
try make me sympathize
with this cunt,
you just had a threesome in class three B,
like what the fuck?
You just have a,
he's supposed to be a dad
or some shit.
- I loved,
that's the one character development that
what the fuck was, Makoto
had that's that was his name.
- Makoto that was his,
'cause he's so fucking blunt.
I couldn't even remember his,
I can't remember any
of the character names.
- I love one character
that all of the Makoto had
is like, he started out as this
absolute simp for sake guy
and then just turned into these most these
most like fucking-
- Kotonaha,
that was her fucking name.
- Yeah.
- He became like the Giga-chat.
- Giga-chat.
(laughing loudly)
- The episode for me that made me
had to pause and go like.
(sighs loudly)
When they wanted to have
a threesome or something.
- Yeah, yeah.
(laughing loudly)
- I like paused it
and I was like.
(laughing loudly)
(Joey clapping)
- Shut them out there,
shut the fucking there.
(laughing loudly)
- I was like, what the fuck is this?
And it was so like porn,
like it was literally a
porn plot, how it happened.
- 'Cause it is a fucking porn plot.
- It is.
- Yeah, it was-
- "School Days HQ" is a porn plot.
- That's the worst thing about it, right?
Is that they try and sell you
that it's not a porn plot.
And then they hit you with
the, in front of my salad plot.
And you're like, no,
this isn't what I want.
And the fact that people on mal
had the fucking balls to be,
this is an artistic
masterpiece of our generation.
(laughing loudly)
- I'm definitely that one
guy, I could say that.
I'm like this ending is absolutely genius.
You guys just throw me
at the thin air.
- The timing is impeccable.
It's like
okay if my dog got rabies
and I've watched it die
for three hours.
Yeah, I'd probably see it put down
but it would be satisfying, right?
Because it's just suffering.
That's what the anime was,
it was just suffering.
I fucking hated it.
And the fact that I had
to then watch 40 minutes
of a let's play or
whatever the fuck it was
in the first thing.
- See I didn't watch that.
- And the worst part was is that imagined,
okay, before you could even
start the dog shit pile
that is fucking "School Days."
You had to watch 40
minutes of the same thing
before you started the same thing again.
So, I remember watching the first episode
already bored out of my mind
'cause I'd seen this shit before
in a slightly different way.
And I was like, okay,
I hate "School Days."
- Listen to this.
- School Days sucks (beep).
- I'm just having a fucking
mental breakdown right now
because I thought I had left
School Days in the past.
I never thought I'd hear
those two words again.
And I never thought I'd be
sitting next to the guy who,
'cause, I remember that mal phase
and I thought everyone must be trolling.
This is like the inter-species
reviewers kind of thing.
Everyone's giving this a 10,
everyone's being fucking ironic.
There's no way that there can be a guy-
- I'm sure there were.
- I'm sure there were,
but I can't imagine you
ironically gave it a 10.
I just can't, I just.
- I just remember like-
- What is happening?
(laughing lightly)
- I had a video
like this is a video-
- Well yeah you corrected
your opinion.
- Yeah, no, no, no.
- Not enough.
- So, I made two videos,
I had a video.
The first video I've
ever made on School Days
was right after I finished watching it.
And I think it's a six-year-old video
and it's called, is the School Days ending
a masterpiece or something like that.
- Oh my God.
- And it was me going
like, yeah, I think it was.
- Yeah, but okay,
imagine "Code Geass" is ending, right.
You heard that,
but then 25 episodes was
just us following Nunally,
just her daily life.
You know what I mean.
That shit's boring, I don't wanna fuck-
- The ending was satisfying
but it was just a boring show.
It was a boring show for half of it.
And then the second half was just
anger management issue.
- I think I gave it such a high score
because I just appreciated the meta behind
how the director and producer
chose the literal worst ending
of any visual novel in existence.
It was a great trolling in my opinion.
And I think that's why I
said it was kind of genius.
- I mean it's definitely different.
That ending like that,
I haven't seen anything
like that since-
- Because there's a reason
why we're still talking about School Days
after fucking how many years
of it since it's been out?
- Yeah okay, here's the thing, right?
Is that sometimes
(laughing lightly)
what is a good ending, right?
Do you think of it as a good ending?
Because the story made sense.
It really like the whole thing,
it was like, wow that's a great ending,
it really made sense.
All the characters built up to this.
No, it's a good ending
because the main character
was fucking awful.
And everyone in that show was god awful.
We just wanted to see
them get like revenge.
- But I would argue that an
ending that is good, right.
It doesn't necessarily have
to be memorable, right.
There is a different
between a memorable ending
and a good ending.
- It's a memorable ending
not a good ending
(laughing lightly).
- It's just like pure shock factor, right.
- Yeah.
- That was like,
it's just like pure shock factor.
And it's got no much substance
behind that shock factor.
- Right, right.
- Right, and that was my big
problem with "School Days."
'Cause at least with the visual novel
you could see fucking sex scenes for one.
(laughing loudly)
- We can watch the Giga-chat in that.
- Get some tips,
he's getting threesomes like age 16,
holy shit.
- Exactly,
'cause at least in that
point it actually made sense
why he was getting all this fucking pussy.
- Did he though, did he really-
- I mean, it made sense
'cause he was a fucking hentai, right?
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- It made sense
in the visual novel, not in the anime
because they didn't explain
the hentai sub plot.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Or the subtext, I guess
that it is a hentai.
- I think that was the
first time as a teenager
that I was like, sex again.
(laughing loudly)
Really?
We're gonna go with sex
again, all right Jeez?
- Yeah but like, around that time, right.
That's like the age where
you start to be beyond those kinds of
like sex and poop jokes.
Where it's all about,
if this isn't challenging
my 16 year old atheist brain
then it's not good material.
- I mean, I'm pretty sure I watched
that like pp ppoo poo
thing that made me laugh
on YouTube like two weeks ago.
(laughing loudly)
So I don't know if I'm fully gone but.
- Right, but it always goes back, right?
You'd laugh at poop jokes
at age 10, not at age 15.
And then you love a poop
jokes as you get to age 20.
- Being a teenager is fucking weird.
That's just like, that's all I can say.
- It is fucking weird,
'cause teenagers we're
horny as fuck, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- And I guess when you're
a teenager you wanna..
This is weird thing that you
don't do as an adult right?
When you're an adult, you
fully accept what you're into.
But as a teenager, you're
like trying to mold
your interest into what you
think you should be right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah exactly.
- And I felt like the
shows that you watched
which is probably why this guy gave
a fucking School Days a 10 he's like
I wanna be this smart
guy who can see through
all the bullshit to see the masterpiece.
- I would fully admit
that's exactly what I did.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, I'm not gonna sit here
and say I did that too, right.
There's probably a part
of me that would argue
that "Prison Break" was a
masterpiece of our time, right.
When I look back now, I'm
like what the was I thinking?
I was 15.
- Yeah.
- When you're a teenager,
you'd have dumb opinions.
- Which is why you should never start
an anime YouTube channel in your teen age.
- No, no, no.
- Because you're very
highly regret it later on.
- My first video was on fucking "Bleach."
(laughing loudly)
- Wait, how old are you, when
you started YouTube then?
- 17.
- Shit, okay.
See, I would do still do dumb up until 20.
- Yeah.
- And I started
my YouTube at 19, right.
- Yeah, I was 19 as well when I started.
- And I holy crap, some of the stuff
that I said that I look back now
and you look back and you know the motives
as well to why you said the dumb shit.
- Yeah, yeah
- You'd never have now.
Right.
- Of course.
- You're like, I want
to be seen in this way.
So I'm gonna say opinion
that isn't really mine
but I know people will view me if I.
- I look back at my,
some of my first videos
and I fucking cringe, man.
I could not finish them.
(laughing loudly)
Oh my God.
- I'm so fucking glad that
the way the internet was
it was like the perfect time
I think for when I was growing up
'cause there was still
the kind of thing of,
you could say whatever the fuck you wanted
and you got away with it, right?
I'm sure I said some
fucking horrible stuff
on Room Escape and Xbox
live to people right?
And I was like-
- Of course.
- Now I mean kind of stuff
gets hold against you.
- Yeah.
- I'm glad that I had
that room to grow, room to know that
School Days was garbage.
Without having to make a video about it.
I mean like School Days
is a masterpiece, guys.
- Yeah, don't make the
same mistake I made.
- Did you actually make a video on that?
- Yeah.
- Well you did?
- You did?
- Yeah.
- Is it up in your channel?
- Yeah, it's on my channel.
- Oh my God.
- It's like a video from six years ago.
And it's like-
- We're watching that tonight.
- It's like five minutes, I mean,
I can't watch it 'cause it's so clingy,
but it's me in a fucking
(laughing loudly)
I had this giant chopper
hat for some reason.
I don't know why I was wearing it.
That was during the era
where I was known as the guy
as to where the weird hats.
I had a chopper hat that
was the huge chopper hat.
And I was also wearing this rainbow beanie
with a scarf attached to it and shit.
I looked gross to say the least
I dunno why anyone was like,
Oh yeah, this guy looks good.
But yeah, an ironically, I was like
you know what,
now that I'd like mulling it over.
I think School Days is ending
is really freaking good.
And it's on my channel right now.
Like, dude.
I'll keep that up because it is-
- It's just getting hard drive,
he's gonna.
(laughing loudly)
- I like to keep it up
to kind of remind my audience
that I used to be like this
but now obviously I've changed
my opinion on School Days
and a lot of shows
because I've, as you said
I've had the room to grow
now and the room to watch.
- I think it's funny to look back
at your old videos where
you were clingy as fuck.
- Yeah.
- Just to be like,
this is what I'm like now.
I mean you can see clear improvement.
- I liked seeing the growth.
That feels good.
It feels it hurts to watch
some of your older videos.
I actually watched it and I'm like
I sound so much more British.
My accent has changed so fucking much.
And I didn't realize that.
- I had such a Northern accent
when I started YouTube.
- Well when I meet you
you had like the thickest
Northern accent and I'm-
- Yeah.
- Yeah it's kind of
been like destroyed now, which is nice.
I mean I speak speak clearly.
- Yeah.
- But I think that's
it to coincide with all
like YouTube growth.
I think you have that as
well, especially in your taste
and anime when you're a teenager
and what you like and you
kind of lie to yourself.
- We're called Trash Taste for a reason.
- Yeah, I mean Joey's is really
pulling his weight on that
Trash Taste, he's really-
- This episode has been on fucking point.
- I had to bring the trash in, all right.
If someone someone's
gonna do is gonna be me.
- Why is it every podcast I'm one,
I can never escape "School Days?"
Why, why?
(laughing loudly)
- 'Cause it's so fun.
- I think it's that
moment as an anime fan,
when you watch School Days
and it's like two paths, which
one are you gonna go down?
Are you're gonna go down like
just admitting your taste.
- This is like the modern day,
like "Pokemon" versus "Digimon."
It's like School Days
good or School Days bad.
- It's like the anime litmus test.
- I'm thinking, was "School Days,"
just way more culturally important
for the anime fandom than
I've realized it was.
- I think it is.
- At least for,
in the mid 2010 that round.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I think that was a big taste indicator.
- 100%.
- And also anyone
who said they liked it
was a fucking liar at the time.
So, and that means you couldn't trust
any of his opinions.
(laughing loudly)
- Anyone subscribed after
that I don't understand.
- Because at that time I remember this
I felt like I was the idiot.
'Cause I'm like the only guy
that thinks the show is garbage.
Like, I'm I going crazy?
- When did School Days come out?
It was like 2007, I think it came.
- It was during the golden age.
- Okay, so its 2007 yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause I think it was 2007.
- Saying that, right.
I watched that at like
2013 and that was just
that argument was still
going on until 2013.
And to some aspect that's
still going on today
obviously a lot lesser, but-
- I mean you can argue
that we brought it back.
- Yeah.
(laughing loudly)
- Well, how many anime do you know
that have had discussions like that
where it's brought up
time and it's so decisive.
- I think this is the only anime
that's properly trashy.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, it's so trashy.
- It just keeps being brought up
'cause I can, point shows
like say "Evangelion"
or something that,
we can discuss till the end of times.
And fans probably we'll discuss
that too at the end of time.
But in terms of shows that
I count as fucking awful.
- School Days is just a show
that just doesn't refuse.
It's a fucking cockroach,
every time I step on it,
every time I think it's fucking died.
- It comes back.
- Two other people
come back and say, I like
the end of the story.
I'm like shut the fuck up.
(laughing loudly)
Please, I thought I was past this point.
- You'll never escape from it, dude.
That's that's the beauty of School Days
- It's 2020, oh my God.
- I love how this was just
supposed to be an origin story
in terms of the downfall of anime.
- It's just the absolute,
roasting of my 10 out of 10 opinion.
(laughing loudly)
- It's just like a Brazzers of anime,
that's basically what it is.
Imagine if a Brazzers had a good ending
we probably all be
arguing about it, right?
That's the equivalent of it.
It's not, it's fucking shit.
God, so heated about it.
It gives like a visceral reaction
to everyone who dislikes it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- This guy's just living it out.
- I'm just looking forward
to the giant discussion.
This is gonna cause in the sub Reddit.
This is gonna be a whole thread again.
This is gonna come out.
- I'm interested to see what you,
the viewers if you have seen School Days
think of it and if you're wrong
on your thoughts of "School Days."
(laughing lightly)
- Yeah.
- Is there anything else we
can talk about other than-
- I think that's a good
place to end it for today?
- I feel like I just took
the wind out of my sails.
I don't know how I can possibly be calm
about anything else today.
(laughing softly)
- But you do have something
important to talk about.
- We do have something to talk about.
We've actually started
the Trash Taste patron
as you can see,
the production value is
quite high for this podcast
and we have editors helping us and stuff.
And it's a whole system that we have
and sadly it doesn't fund it's self-
- It cost a lot of money to run.
- Basically, I just
wanna talk about, because
I feel like when we
were making this podcast
we didn't wanna settle for
cheap production values, right.
- We wanted this to be,
comparable to any other
high budget podcast.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, but like,
to us, this was a passion project.
We've put quite a lot of
our own savings into this.
That's an understatement.
- It's like super expensive.
(laughing lightly)
- Like several thousand
dollars to making this
and plus, we are renting
out a studio, in Japan.
- A lot of time, a lot of money.
- Yeah, near Tokyo.
So right now, not to say that we,
all three of us are pretty well off.
- We're probably fine (laugh).
- We're probably fine.
We just don't want our passion project
to be bleeding money,
which right now it is.
- Yeah.
- So any help that
you can give to help us just to
go even 'cause that's my goal.
If I can just do this and not have
to worry about-
- to worry about losing money.
- Like just constantly losing money
and then I would be more comfortable
and I would just be happy.
- And hopefully with
your guys' support too,
like we'll be able to evolve this podcast
into like bigger and better
things in the near future.
- Yeah, and if you want
us to stand the viewer
who doesn't care about patron,
anything, don't worry about it.
Nothing will change to your Trash Taste.
It's gonna be exact same way.
You get everything, don't worry about it.
The patrons don't get anything.
We're not gonna pay wall anything.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And please, again,
we'll be fine financially
if you don't support
it, it's totally fine.
It's purely optional.
- Purely optional.
- If you like the podcasts.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And is that, what else
do we have to discuss?
Anything else we need to
shout out or anything?
- Follow us on Twitter.
- We have Twitter, yeah.
- @TrashTastePod.
You can also send us your memes
and topic suggestions there as well.
And we also post photos and
videos of dumb shit that we do.
So if you enjoy that,
follow us on there as well.
- Smash the like button.
- And subscribe to the channel.
- And before you fuck ask again
it will be going on Spotify
and Apple, all that stuff.
Eventually, if it isn't already,
it will be soon, don't worry.
- At the time of recording.
I'm really hoping by
the time this comes out,
it's already, so check the description.
I'm sure we're gonna have
an answer in the description
whether this would be in Spotify.
- We'll definitely announce
it on the sub Reddit
and Twitter.
- Yeah.
- So at least check that out.
- But without further ado,
this has been Trash Taste.
And thanks for watching guys.
- See you in the next episode.
- Yeah.
- Bye.
I can't fucking believe School Days-
(laughing loudly).
- This fucker.
(upbeat music)